This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Let's say someone wanted to buy one of your eyes. Would you go for it? I wouldn't sell my eyes. No. Because side is precious. Okay, but would you say yes for a million dollars? No.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。假设有人想买你的一个眼睛，你会同意吗？我不会卖掉我的眼睛。不会。因为视力太珍贵了。好吧，但如果是100万美元，你肯说“好”吗？不会。
No. No. Because I had a lot of vision problems growing up and I already have like resolved that. I went through lay six and I'm like, good now. What about $10 million? Well. I don't think so. Yeah, I'm going to still say, I'm going to pass, yeah.
不会。不会。因为我小时候有很严重的视力问题，而且我好不容易才解决掉。我做过激光视力矫正手术，现在感觉挺好。那1000万美元呢？嗯。我觉得不会。好吧，我还是拒绝吧，是的。
If you said $10 million, tell you I'm building a house in Honduras, I'm helping the fam, I'm just like, have an eye patch on like slick rig and we good. Maybe you're listening to this and thinking, hey, if someone prefers $10 million over two eyes, well, that's their business. Or maybe you think commodifying human eyes in this way is just wrong. Our hypothetical marketplace for eyes is one example of what economists sometimes refer to
如果你说1000万美元，我会告诉你我在洪都拉斯建房子，我在帮衬家人，我就会像一个戴着眼罩的时尚海盗，这就很棒了。也许你听到这里会想，嘿，如果有人更喜欢1000万美元而不是两只眼睛，好吧，那是他们自己的事。或者你可能认为以这种方式将人类眼睛商品化是完全错误的。我们假设的眼睛市场就是经济学家有时所说的
as repugnant transactions. They make us uneasy. They force us to define the boundaries of what is acceptable to buy and sell. They put morality into conflict with economics. And he said, I'm going to pay you 100 euros if you're going to touch something more on your forehead. In a family court in Hackensack, New Jersey, She's my child.
令人反感的交易的一个例子。它们让我们感到不安。它们迫使我们划定买卖行为的可接受边界。它们将道德与经济学置于对立面。他说，如果你愿意在额头上多纹点东西，我要付你100欧元。在新泽西州哈肯萨克的家庭法庭上，她是我的孩子。
One surrogate mother has refused to give up the baby. And I know what she wants and what she needs. It's not clear as a society that we want everything that we disapprove of to be against the law. Studying what makes us uneasy can reveal interesting things about human behavior and the evolution of our social norms. The psychology of repugnant transactions this week on Hidden Brain. It's illegal in the state of California to buy or sell horse meat. So when you come to California we have many fine restaurants but none of them will serve sell horse meat. So when you come to California, we have many fine restaurants, but none of them will serve
一位代孕母亲拒绝放弃这个孩子。我知道她想要什么以及她需要什么。作为社会，我们并不清楚是否希望所有我们不赞同的事都成为违法行为。研究是什么让我们感到不安，可以揭示关于人类行为和社会规范演变的有趣见解。令人反感的交易的心理学，本周《隐藏的大脑》。在加利福尼亚州，买卖马肉是违法的。所以当你来到加州时，我们有许多不错的餐厅，但没有一家会提供马肉。所以当你来到加州时，我们有许多不错的餐厅，但没有一家会提供
you horse meat. My guest today spends a lot of time thinking about things like horse meat. Al Roth is an economist at Stanford University. He won the 2012 Nobel Prize in Economics, and he's coined the term, Repugnant Transactions. We have no laws in California against drinking spit or eating worms. Probably because no one wants to do that. The reason we have a law against eating horse meat in California
你马肉。我今天的嘉宾花了很多时间思考像马肉这样的事情。埃尔·罗斯是斯坦福大学的经济学家。他获得了2012年诺贝尔经济学奖，并且他创造了“令人反感的交易”这个词。在加州，我们没有关于喝口水或吃虫子的法律。可能因为没有人想做那种事。我们在加州有禁止吃马肉的法律，
is because some people like to eat horse meat and other people don't think that they should be allowed to. So when I talk about a repugnant transaction, the short version I give is that it's a transaction that some people would like to engage in, and other people don't think they should be allowed to, even if it's hard to see how those other people are harmed. way to turn a perfectly acceptable donation or exchange into a repugnant transaction is by introducing the element of money. It's against the law almost everywhere in the world to pay a kidney donor, or a living kidney donor for a kidney for transplantation. It's a lovely thing if someone loves you enough to donate a kidney to save your life.
是因为有些人喜欢吃马肉，而其他人认为不应该允许这样做。所以当我谈到令人反感的交易时，我的简短定义是：这是一些人想要进行的交易，而其他人认为不应该被允许，即便很难看出那些其他人受到了什么伤害。将一笔完全可以接受的捐赠或交换变成令人反感的交易的方法，就是引入金钱因素。在世界上几乎所有地方，付钱给肾脏捐赠者，或者为了移植手术付钱给活体肾脏捐赠者都是违法的。如果有个人爱你到足以捐出一个肾脏来拯救你的生命，这是一件很美好的事。
That's possible because Healthy people have two kidneys and can remain healthy with one But it's illegal to buy a kidney with Everywhere in the world with the single exception of the Islamic Republic of Iran Huh where there is a monetary market for kidneys. So let's just look at that in a little bit more detail We'll come to Iran in just a second But there's something interesting here, which is that if I donate my kidney to my friend, I'm a hero. But if I try and sell my kidney to my friend, I'm something of a jerk. You're well, you're a felon in the United States. That's right. So, it's an unusual state
这是因为健康的人有两个肾，少了一个也能保持健康。但到处买肾都是违法的，世界上只有一个例外，那就是伊朗伊斯兰共和国。哈！那里存在一个肾脏的货币市场。所以让我们更详细地探讨一下。我们马上就会谈到伊朗，但这里有一个有趣的现象，那就是如果我把肾捐给我的朋友，我就是个英雄。但如果我试图把肾卖给我的朋友，我就是个混蛋。在美国，你会被视为重罪犯。没错。所以，这是一个不同寻常的状态，
of the world in the sense that it's universally acknowledged that you own your kidneys, but you're not allowed to sell the kidney, nor am I allowed to buy one. What is it do you think about the introduction of money that changes this transaction from being a heroic transaction to one that is really seen as repugnant? I think it has something to do with people's idea about what kinds of things should go on in close family circles and what kinds of things should go on in relatively impersonal markets.
从某种意义上说，人们普遍承认你的肾属于你，但你既不被允许出售肾脏，我也不被允许购买。你认为是什么原因，导致金钱的引入将这场交易从英雄般的行为变成了一场真正被视为令人反感的交易？我认为这与人们对以下事物的看法有关：哪些事应该在亲密家庭圈子里发生，哪些事应该在相对非个人的市场中发生。
So over the long course of human history, we've gone from doing everything with people we know to doing many things with people we don't know or it might be quite distant. There's also a slippery slope concern that if people could sell their kidneys, maybe we would feel less of a social obligation to take care of poor people because after all, they have a kidney, they could sell it. And there's a moral repugnance that comes into play that people often talk about, that people should always be ends in themselves and never means and for me to buy your kidney might be to
因此，在人类漫长的历史长河中，我们已经从和认识的人做所有事，过渡到和我们不认识或距离相当遥远的人做许多事。还有一个循序渐进的滑坡隐患：如果人们可以出售自己的肾脏，也许我们照顾穷人的社会责任感就会减少，因为毕竟他们有一个肾可以卖。还有一个发挥作用的道德反感，人们经常讨论这一点：人应当始终是自身的目的，而永不只是手段；对我而言，购买你的肾脏可能是在
to commodify you to objectify you. Now of course what makes it particularly unusual is you can give me your kidney. So you own your kidney, you own it securely enough that you could give it to me if you wished, but you can't sell it to me. So there's obviously a moral argument to be made against monetizing the sale of kidneys. But there's also a moral argument in some ways in favor of doing it, as you and others have pointed out, thousands of people die each year waiting for a kidney donor. And at the same time, there are millions of people walking around with a spare kidney that they don't need.
将你商品化、将你客体化。当然，让这件事变得特别不同寻常的是，你可以把你的肾送给我。所以你的肾属于你，它归属于你，足够安全，如果你愿意，你可以把它送给我，但你不能把它卖给我。因此，反对将肾脏买卖货币化的道德论点显而易见。但在某些方面，正如你和其他人所指出的那样，也有支持这样做的道德论点——每年有成千上万的人在等待肾脏捐赠中死去。与此同时，数以百万计的人身上带着他们不需要的多余肾脏到处走动。
And economists might say there's an obvious solution here. Yes. don't need, and economists might say there's an obvious solution here. Yes, yes. Kidney disease is one of the top 10 causes of death among human beings worldwide. So it's a big deal. And here in the United States, this morning there are about 100,000 people on the waiting list for a deceased donor kidney. And we only expect to get about 13,000 deceased donor kidneys for transplantation each year. So the weight is long and it's dangerous, and as you say, thousands of people die each year while waiting, and waiting is no fun. Dialysis keeps you alive, but having to undergo dialysis might prevent you from being able to work, for instance, or leading a normal
经济学家可能会说，这里有一个显而易见的解决方案。是的。不需要，经济学家可能会说，这里有一个显而易见的解决方案。是的，是的。肾脏疾病是全球人类十大死因之一。所以这是一件大事。在美国，今天早上大约有10万人排在等待逝者捐赠肾脏的名单上。而我们每年预计只能获得大约13,000个用于移植的逝者肾脏。所以等待是漫长而危险的，正如你所说，每年有成千上万的人在等待中死去，而且等待一点也不好玩。透析能让你维持生命，但不得不接受透析可能会阻止你进行工作，或者过上正常的
life. So, one question is, what would happen in the thought experiment where you actually are able to buy and sell kidneys? And as you mentioned a little while ago, there is a country where this is legally possible. Tell me what happens in Iran and whether they have the same organ shortages that we have in the United States.
生活。所以，其中一个问题是，在你真正能够买卖肾脏的思想实验中会发生这种情况吗？正如你刚才提到的，有一个国家在法律上是可行的。告诉我伊朗发生了什么，以及他们是否像美国一样面临同样的器官短缺问题。
Well, we're gonna learn a lot more about that in the near future because my colleague here at Stanford, Mohammed Akbar, poor and some of his colleagues are studying that and so we'll get very reliable information soon. But the story is that it's not that there's no waiting time, it still takes time to arrange a kidney, but it's substantially shorter than in countries that that primarily depend on the deceased donation and on altruistic donation of kidneys by living donors. So it seems to be working well in some respect, but not so well in other respects. Apparently, when you interview organ donor sellers in Iran, often they wish to remain anonymous. So it's a legal transaction, but it's not one that
嗯，我们在不久的将来会对此有更多的了解，因为我在斯坦福大学的同事穆罕默德·阿克巴尔·普尔和他的同事们正在研究这个问题，所以我们很快就会获得非常可靠的信息。但事实是，并不是说没有等待时间，安排一个肾脏仍然需要时间，但它比那些主要依赖逝者捐赠以及活体捐赠者出于利他主义捐赠肾脏的国家要短得多。所以它在某些方面似乎运作良好，但在其他方面则不然。显然，当你采访伊朗的器官捐赠出售者时，他们通常希望保持匿名。所以这是一笔合法的交易，但并不是一笔
they're happy to have advertised to their friends and colleagues that they've done. So that suggests that it's operating in something of a shadow. When we talk about repugnant transactions in general, you see other repugnant transactions that becoming legal doesn't make them unrepugnant. Without meaning to draw any parallels at all between kidney donation and Iran, prostitution is legal in Germany, but I don't get the sense that sex workers in Germany write home to their families about how their work day is going, even though it's legal. In 2018, a group of men celebrating a bachelor party in Spain approached a homeless man named Tomek and offered him cash in exchange for tattooing the groom's name on his forehead.
他们乐意向朋友和同事宣扬自己做过的事。这表明它在某种程度上处于暗处。当我们总体上谈论令人反感的交易时，你会发现其他令人反感的交易，即使合法化也不会消除其令人反感的本质。无意在肾脏捐赠和伊朗之间做任何类比，卖淫在德国是合法的，但我不觉得德国的性工作者会给家里写信谈论他们的一天工作过得怎么样，尽管这是合法的。2018年，一群在西班牙庆祝单身派对的男子接近了一名无家可归的男子托梅克，并向他提供现金，交换条件是在他的额头上纹上新郎的名字。
Here is Tomek in a video published by the German website, Ruppli. And he said, I'm going to pay you 100 euro. If you're going to touch something more on your forehead. 100 euros for me is quite a lot. So I say, yeah, okay, why not? So, you know, this certainly sounds exploitative. On the other hand, it's not clear that every vile transaction should be illegal. It doesn't make us think better of the man who's getting married, you know, perhaps the young woman who is about to marry him should update her preferences. So as an economist, I'm trying to, I'd love you to try and explain for me what the difference is between these two different kinds of transactions.
这是德国网站Ruppli发布的视频中的托梅克。他说，我要付给你100欧元。如果你愿意在额头上多纹点东西。100欧元对我来说是一大笔钱。所以我说，好吧，为什么不呢？所以，你知道，这听起来确实具有剥削性。另一方面，并不清楚每一笔卑劣的交易都应该是非法的。这并不会让我们对那个要结婚的男子产生更好的看法，你知道，也许那个即将嫁给他的年轻女性应该更新她的择偶偏好。所以作为一名经济学家，我希望你能试着为我解释这两种不同交易之间的区别。
On the one hand, if I tell you Al Roth, I'm going to pay you $100 million to get a tattoo on your forehead. That seems truly wrong and obnoxious. On the other hand, if I tell you, I'm Stanford University and I'm going to hire you Al Roth to teach my economics class and I'm going to pay you X amount of dollars to do that, that feels perfectly above board. They're both in some ways transactions. You're providing some kind of a service, or you're doing something for me that involves yourself. In both cases, you're getting paid. Why does one seem so problematic? So I'm not quite sure. It's hard to draw lines between the things that are just... should be just on one side of the line and just on the other.
一方面，如果我告诉你，埃尔·罗斯，我要付给你1亿美元让你在额头上纹身。这看起来真的很不对劲，而且令人讨厌。另一方面，如果我告诉你，我是斯坦福大学，我要聘请你埃尔·罗斯来教我的经济学课，并且为此付给你一定数量的美元，这感觉完全光明正大。从某种意义上说，它们都是交易。你提供某种服务，或者为我做一些涉及你自身的事情。在这两种情况下，你都得到了报酬。为什么其中一个看起来那么有问题？所以我不太确定。很难在那些应该刚好划在分界线一侧
should be just on one side of the line and just on the other. One of the reasons I think this should be of interest to economists is that the philosophical discussion and the discussion in the ethics literature often seems to be a little confused. One of the things that they talk about is coercion, and one of the ways they define coercion, this is having to do with adding money to transactions that might not otherwise involve money like surrogacy or like donating eggs for fertility or donating plasma or blood. One of the things they say is something is coercive. Money is coercive. If you do it for the money and in the absence of money, you wouldn't do it. But my guess is you make many more radio broadcasts than you would if you weren't paid for it.
和刚好在另一侧的事物之间划清界限。我认为这应该引起经济学家兴趣的原因之一是，哲学讨论和伦理文献中的讨论往往显得有些混乱。他们讨论的事情之一是胁迫，他们定义胁迫的方式之一与将金钱加入到原本可能不涉及金钱的交易中有关，比如代孕、为生育捐赠卵子或捐赠血浆或血液。他们说的一件事是某事具有胁迫性。金钱具有胁迫性。如果你为了钱而做这件事，而如果没有钱你就不会做。但我的猜测是，你做过的广播节目要比如果没有报酬时做得多得多。
And as you say, I teach more economics classes than I would if I weren't paid for it. But I don't feel coerced and I'm betting you don't feel coerced. We feel paid, we feel appreciated for the work that we do. So at least to an economist, it's not obviously coercive to say to someone, I'll pay you to do something that you otherwise wouldn't do. So the question is, is there some deeper meaning,
正如你所说，我教的经济学课程也比没有报酬时要多。但我不觉得受到胁迫，我敢打赌你也不觉得受到胁迫。我们觉得得到了报酬，觉得我们所做的工作受到了赞赏。因此，至少对经济学家而言，对某人说“我付钱让你做你原本不会做的事”并不是显而易见的胁迫。所以问题是，是否存在某种更深层的含义，
maybe that the ethicists and philosophers are missing, that might nevertheless support their intuition that some things are coercive? And we had a, there's a professor at University of Toronto who got his PhD here at Stanford a few years ago named Sandra Amboelle Who's been doing laboratory experiments in which among other things he tries to see whether he can harm you by paying you too much and Sure enough the more you pay people the more often they they take a money losing gamble
也许是伦理学家和哲学家所遗漏的，但它仍然能够支持他们的直觉，即某些事情具有胁迫性？多伦多大学有一位教授，几年前在这里的斯坦福大学获得了博士学位，名叫桑德拉·昂博尔，他一直在做实验室实验，在实验中他试图通过给你太多钱来看看他是否会伤害你，果不其然，你付给人们的钱越多，他们越是经常进行亏钱的赌博。
so At least his experiment gives us some indication that if we want to talk about least his experiment gives us some indication that if we want to talk about informed consent, we have to take incentives very seriously. It might be harder to get fully informed consent when the transaction seems more tempting to engage in. And so the interesting thing from an economist's point of view is that you would say if someone pays you more for the same product, then you should take it because your welfare is improving. But at an intuitive level, I think it is clear that if I paid you $100 million for one of your eyes, it does feel like I'm trying to course you into making a bad decision.
所以，至少他的实验给我们提供了一个迹象，如果我们想讨论至少他的实验给我们提供了一个迹象，如果我们想讨论知情同意，我们就必须非常认真地对待激励措施。当交易看起来更具诱惑力时，要获得完全的知情同意可能会更难。因此，从经济学家的角度来看，有趣的地方在于，你会说如果有人为相同的产物付给你更多钱，那么你应该接受，因为你的福利正在改善。但在直觉层面上，我认为很明显，如果我为你的一只眼睛付给你1亿美元，这确实感觉像是我在试图胁迫你做出糟糕的决定。
It does, of course, for $100 million, it might be less of a bad decision, right? So I'd have to form an opinion of how much, $100 million would change my life and how much, having only one eye would reduce my quality of life. And that might be a difficult decision to make. And of course, could I give you the one of my eyes that doesn't work as well as the other, for instance? So we'd both have to be well informed.
确实如此，当然，对于1亿美元来说，这可能算是一个不那么糟糕的决定，对吧？所以我必须评估1亿美元会如何改变我的生活，以及只有一只眼会如何降低我的生活质量。这可能是一个很难做出的决定。当然，我可以把我那只不如另一只眼睛好用的眼睛给你，对吧？所以我们俩都必须充分了解情况。
You know, one of the other concerns about buying kidneys from people is, you know, supposing I have one eye that doesn't work very well, you might get that one. And you'd be more likely to get that one than if I was only giving an eye to someone who I really loved and wanted to see very well. And I would know that my eye might not work so well for them. But the issue of, can you pay for blood plasma, for example, there was a time when it was hard to test for various diseases. And so in the United States and elsewhere, we have a long tradition that whole blood is
你知道，关于从人们那里购买肾脏的另一个担忧是，假设我有一只眼睛不太好用，你可能会拿到那只。而且你拿到那只眼睛的可能性，会比我只是把眼睛捐给一个我真正深爱并希望他视力非常好的人要高。而且我会知道我的眼睛对他们来说可能没那么好用。但关于是否可以为血浆付费的问题，例如，曾有一段时间很难检测各种疾病。因此，在美国和其他地方，我们有一个悠久的传统，即全血是
donated altruistically. You don't get paid for whole blood in the United States. But you can get paid for plasma. And as a result, the United States exports lots of plasma products that are important medicines into furon and albumin and clotting factor. Now in Canada, as we speak, recently laws have been passed against paying plasma donors. And Canada imports millions of dollars of plasma products each year from the United States. So there's a sense in which in Canada they're taking the point of view that it would be wrong to
出于利他主义捐赠的。在美国，全血是不能获得报酬的。但你可以为血浆获得报酬。因此，美国出口了大量血浆产品，这些产品是重要的药物，包括纤维蛋白原、白蛋白和凝血因子。现在在加拿大，正如我们所说，最近通过了禁止向血浆捐赠者支付报酬的法律。而加拿大每年从美国进口数百万美元的血浆产品。所以在某种意义上，加拿大的观点是：向加拿大人支付血浆捐赠报酬是错误的，但从
pay Canadians to donate plasma, but it's quite alright to buy plasma products from pharmaceutical companies that get plasma from Americans. Plasma from Americans. Ideas of what is repugnant, very not just from country to country, but from era to era. When we come back, we discuss the role that technology plays in pushing the boundaries of what we consider repugnant. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantham. In 1986, a woman named Mary Beth Whitehead gave birth to a girl who eventually came to be known in headlines around the world as Baby M. The trial in the matter of Baby M began today in Hacken's Sack, New Jersey. Baby M is a nine-month-old girl born to a surrogate mother.
获取美国血浆的制药公司购买血浆产品是完全没问题的。什么是令人反感的观念，不仅因国家而异，也因时代而异。当我们回来时，我们将讨论技术在推动我们认为令人反感的界限方面所起的作用。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。1986年，一个名叫玛丽·贝思·怀特黑德的女人生下了一个女孩，这个女孩后来在世界各地的头条新闻中被称为“M婴儿”。关于M婴儿案的审判今天在新泽西州哈肯萨克开始。M婴儿是一个9个月大的女孩，由代孕母亲所生。
Al Roth picks up the story. There was a New York couple that was unable to bear a baby for some reason, and they contracted with a surrogate mom to bear the baby for them. And they did what today is called traditional surrogacy. That is the man's sperm and the surrogate mom's egg were used. The baby was brought to term by the surrogate mom and transferred to the New York couple that had contracted for this surrogacy.
埃尔·罗斯接过了话头。有一对纽约夫妇由于某种原因无法生育婴儿，他们与代孕母亲签约为他们生下孩子。他们做了今天被称为传统代孕的事情。也就是使用了男方的精子和代孕母亲的卵子。婴儿由代孕母亲足月产下，并移交给签约进行这次代孕的纽约夫妇。
But the surrogate mom later regretted this and there was a custody battle. And it was a complicated custody battle because the surrogate mom was the genetic mom. She's my child and I know what she wants and what she needs. And I'm only the only one that could know that because of carrying her the nine months, carrying for her for the first four months. I know her needs. From Hackensack, New Jersey, today, a decision in the baby M trial. The judge in the case has upheld the legality of the surrogate mother agreement
但代孕母亲后来感到后悔，于是发生了一场抚养权之战。这是一场复杂的抚养权之战，因为代孕母亲是基因上的母亲。她是我的孩子，我知道她想要什么以及她需要什么。我是唯一一个能知道这一点的人，因为我怀了她九个月，在前四个月照顾了她。我了解她的需求。今天来自新泽西州哈肯萨克的报道，M婴儿案有了判决。此案的法官维持了代孕母亲协议的合法性，
and has given undisputed custody of the baby girl to her father, William Stern. So, New York outlawed surrogacy in the wake of that custody battle. Opponents of surrogate parenting say a New Jersey Supreme Court decision in the baby M.K.s marks the end of surrogate contracts, the state court. But in California where I live, surrogacy has been legal for a long time, and the form of surrogacy that's legal is gestational surrogacy. So an embryo is implanted into the surrogate's womb, so the surrogate is not genetically related to the baby. And there are reliable legal contracts and ways
并将女婴无可争议的抚养权判给了她的父亲威廉·斯特恩。因此，纽约在那场抚养权之战后宣布代孕为非法。代孕育儿的反对者称，新泽西州最高法院对M婴儿案的裁决标志着该州法院代孕合同的终结。但在我居住的加州，代孕长期以来一直是合法的，而且合法的代孕形式是妊娠代孕。因此，胚胎被植入代孕者的子宫，所以代孕者与婴儿没有基因上的亲缘关系。加州有可靠的法律合同和处理方式，
of going about this in California, so that if you have a surrogate baby in California, your name can be on the California birth certificate as the parent. Millions of people around the world suffer from extraordinarily painful fertility issues. Their desire to be parents sometimes comes into conflict with society's attitudes about the appropriate way to have a child. The entire supply chain of having a baby, as Al-Rot sometimes puts it, can now be
这样如果你在加州生下一个代孕婴儿，你的名字就可以作为父母写在加州的出生证明上。世界各地有数百万人遭受着极其痛苦的生育问题折磨。他们成为父母的渴望有时会与社会关于生孩子的适当方式的态度发生冲突。正如埃尔·罗斯有时所说的那样，生孩子的整个供应链，现在可以通过精子捐赠、卵子捐赠和代孕的结合来
outsourced through a combination of sperm and egg donation and surrogacy. Some people might find that problematic, but I'll point out that any individual part of that supply chain is less controversial than the sum of its parts. Especially now that we allow same-sex marriage so that there are lesbian households that don't have sperm and there are gay male households that don't have a womb between them. So being able to buy sperm when you don't have viable sperm between you and being able to buy eggs when you don't have eggs between you and being able to rent a womb when you don't have a womb between you working womb all seem to me to be somewhat less problematic than
外包。有些人可能会觉得这有问题，但我会指出，供应链中的任何单个部分都比其各个部分的加总争议要小。特别是现在我们允许同性婚姻，因此有些女同性恋家庭没有精子，有些男同性恋家庭没有子宫。因此，当你和你之间没有可用的精子时能够买精子，当你之间没有卵子时能够买卵子，以及当你之间没有一个能工作的子宫时能够租一个子宫，在我看来，这些似乎都比
buying the whole supply chain. If you think buying the whole supply chain of having a baby is repugnant, consider the changes that have unfolded when it comes to each part of that supply chain. In retro fertilization example, was once seen as controversial. Technology and time have changed that. Over time, technology gives us different options than we had in the past, and we see some of the new options as repugnant, and then over time, as we get used to them, we see them as less repugnant.
买下整个供应链问题要少一些。如果你认为买下生孩子的整个供应链是令人反感的，想想围绕供应链各个部分展开的变革吧。以体外受精为例，曾经被视为充满争议。技术和时间改变了这一点。随着时间推移，技术为我们提供了过去没有的不同选择，我们认为其中一些新选择是令人反感的，然后随着时间推移，当我们习惯了它们，我们就会觉得它们没那么令人反感。
So, in vitro fertilization was just developed in the 1970s. It was a Nobel Prize. It was regarded with some repugnance when it was developed, that you could implant an embryo, so have a baby that didn't result from sex. And of course, it also made possible gestational surrogacy. So, all of a sudden, a woman could bear a child who wasn't genetically related. I think in vitro fertilization, which as I said, want to know about FISE, I think it's successfully gotten over the repugnant hub. Not everyone approves of it, but it's widely approved of. It's a standard part of medical care for fertility.
所以，体外受精是在20世纪70年代才刚刚发展起来的。这是一项诺贝尔奖成果。它刚开发时曾伴随着一些反感，即你可以植入一个胚胎，从而生出一个不由性行为产生的婴儿。当然，这也使妊娠代孕成为可能。因此，突然之间，一个女性可以孕育一个与自己没有基因亲缘关系的孩子。我认为体外受精，正如我所说，想要了解体外受精，我认为它已经成功跨越了反感的坎。并非所有人都赞同它，但它得到了广泛认可。它是生育医疗护理的标准部分。
So technology made some new things possible. Some of them were regarded as repugnant for some time and then we got used to them. Some might still be regarded as repugnant. So what's interesting is that when we think about repugnant transactions, I think many of us are using an intuitive system to say I think this feels this feels wrong. And what what you might be hinting at in some ways is that that intuition might actually comprise of different, it might be comprised of different things. In other words, part of it might be a moral problem, part of it might be a safety problem, part
所以技术使一些新事物成为可能。其中一些在一段时间内被视为令人反感，然后我们习惯了它们。有些可能仍然被视为令人反感。所以有趣的是，当我们思考令人反感的交易时，我想我们许多人都在使用一种直觉系统来表达“我觉得这感觉不对”。你在某种程度上可能暗示的是，这种直觉实际上可能包含不同的东西，它可能由不同的事物组成。换句话说，一部分可能是道德问题，一部分可能是安全问题，一部分
of it might be a money problem. And what our minds are doing in some ways are integrating all of those to create the intuition of the whole thing is wrong. But as technology progresses and as things become safer, part of that falls away. I think you're absolutely right that repugnant is a big net into which I'm allowing things to be classified together. My colleague Debressatz, who's a philosopher here at Stanford, thinks that I'm casting it too widely. For just the reason you say that repugnant is a lot of different things.
可能是金钱问题。我们的头脑在某种程度上正在将所有这些整合起来，从而产生“整件事是错误的”这种直觉。但随着技术进步以及事物变得更加安全，其中的一部分会逐渐消失。我认为你的绝对正确，“令人反感”是一个很大的网，我允许各种事物被归类在一起。我的同事德布雷萨茨是斯坦福大学的一位哲学家，他认为我撒网太宽了。原因正如你所说，令人反感包含许多不同的事情。
Things are repugnant for different reasons. One advantage of casting that wide net is that it lets owl think about situations that on the surface appear innocuous. You can have repugnant transactions, even when no one is harmed, no organs are exchanged, and neither sex nor babies are involved. If you invite me to dinner at your house, I can do a lot of things. I can bring a nice bottle of wine. I can say to you, afterward, you really must come to dinner at our house.
事物因为不同的原因而令人反感。撒下那张大网的一个好处是，它让“猫头鹰”能够思考那些表面上看起来无害的情况。即使没有人受到伤害，没有器官被交换，也没有涉及性或婴儿，你也会有令人反感的交易。如果你邀请我去你家吃晚饭，我可以做很多事情。我可以带一瓶好酒。我可以在事后对你说，你们真的必须来我们家吃晚饭。
One thing I can't do after the dinner is take out my wallet and say, you're such a good cook. That would have cost me $75 at a nice restaurant. Can I just put that down by my plate here to thank you for the dinner? And your reaction, of course, sensibly enough, would be, we're not a restaurant. Why does he think he can pay us for this dinner?
晚饭后我不能做的一件事是掏出钱包说，你做饭真好。这在一家高档餐厅得花我75美元。我可以把它放在我的盘子旁边来感谢你的晚餐吗？当然，你的反应会很合理，我们会说，我们不是餐厅。为什么他会认为他可以为这顿晚饭付钱给我们？
And it's because being invited to dinner at your house is an invitation to be your friend. And when I pay at a restaurant, I completely obliterate my debt. I go to the restaurant, they present me with a bill, I pay it, I don't have to invite them to my house, I don't have to bring them a bottle of wine, I don't have to be nice to them in the future,
这是因为被邀请去你家吃晚饭是成为你朋友的邀请。而当我在餐厅付钱时，我完全消除了我的债务。我去了餐厅，他们给我账单，我付钱，我不用请他们来我家，我不用给他们带一瓶酒，我在未来也不用对他们好，
I don't have to ever come back. But when you invite me to your house, there's at least the idea that maybe we'll become friends and you'll come to dinner at my house and we'll go to coffee together sometime when we're when we're both at Los Angeles. And by by offering to pay you which wasn't what you had in mind at all, I guess I'm making it look like I think I can extinguish my debt as if you're a restaurant. So so even economists understand that sometimes adding money to a transaction is inappropriate. I'm wondering if one problem with paying for your dinner at a friend's house is that it makes what
我甚至永远不用再来。但当你邀请我去你家时，至少有一种想法是，也许我们会成为朋友，你会来我家吃晚饭，当我们都在洛杉矶时，有时我们会一起去喝咖啡。而通过提出向你付钱——这根本不是你脑子里的想法——我想我把它弄得好像我觉得我可以摆脱我的债务，就好像你是一家餐厅。所以，即使是经济学家也明白，有时向交易中加钱是不合适的。我在想，在朋友家吃晚饭付钱的一个问题是，它使原本
actually might be a transaction visible in ways that it might not be otherwise. So in other words, if I invite you over to my house and you have a nice dinner at my house, there is some expectation that you will reciprocate at some point and maybe not with the dinner, maybe something else, but we are essentially trading favors back and forth, we're doing nice things for one another and that's what friends do. But at some level, you could argue that this is a transaction. It's not a transaction in money, it's a transaction in activities. And in some ways, by bringing money into the picture, what we've done is make
可能是一笔交易的事情以一种原本可能不会展现的方式显现出来。换句话说，如果我邀请你来我家，你在我家吃了一顿丰盛的晚餐，这就有一种期望，即你在某个时候会进行回报，也许不是一顿晚餐，也许是别的东西，但我们本质上是在来来回回地交易人情，我们在为彼此做美好的事情，这就是朋友所做的事。但在某种程度上，你可以辩称这是一笔交易。它不是用金钱交易，而是用行动交易。在某种程度上，通过把金钱带入画面，我们所做的是让
a transaction that is implicit into a transaction that's explicit and what's repugnant is that we don't like those transactions being made explicit. That's I think part of what's repugnant, but also there's this idea that transactions in kind might be more intimate than transactions in money. And this might have to do with this ancient idea that before we invented money, many of our transactions were repeated interactions. And as you say, we traded favors. So I think no one objects if when you invite me to dinner, I bring an unusually expensive
一个隐式的交易变成了一个显式的交易，而令人反感的是我们不喜欢让这些交易变得显式。我认为这是令人反感的一部分，但也有这样一种想法：实物交易可能比金钱交易更具亲密感。这可能与这个古老的想法有关：在发明金钱之前，我们的许多交易都是重复的互动。正如你所说，我们交易人情。所以我认为当你在邀请我吃晚饭时我带了一瓶异常昂贵的酒，没有人会反对，对吧？
bottle of wine, right? That could be flamboyant, but it's not offensive. Because we could drink the wine with dinner. So money suggests something, a more arms-length transaction, I think. I like New Yorker cartoons, and there's one I sometimes think of when we have this kind of discussion about a man coming in the door at dinner, holding in his hand a bill, you can't see the denomination of the bill, and he says, we were going to bring wine, but didn't get around to it, this is what we would have spent. A lot of economists have studied what they might call the idiocy of gift exchanges, and
那可能很浮夸，但并不冒犯。因为我们可以把酒留着晚餐时喝。因此，我认为金钱暗示了一些更疏离的交易。我喜欢纽约客漫画，每当我们进行这种关于一个人在晚餐时走进门，手里拿着一张账单（你看不到账单的面额），他说“我们本来要带酒，但没来得及，这就是我们会花掉的钱”的讨论时，我有时会想起这幅漫画。许多经济学家研究了他们可能称之为礼品交换的白痴行为，
this might be especially true around Christmas time. You get me a sweater that I hate, and I get you a toaster that you don't need. And some economists have gone so far as to propose that really what we should be doing is trading gift cards and cash because we'd actually end up not buying each other things that we don't need. But of course, that runs into the problem for repugnant transactions, which is if I actually gave my partner or my friends cash for every birthday party or anniversary, I'm not going to be seen as a very good friend.
在圣诞节前后尤其如此。你给我买了一件我讨厌的毛衣，我给你买了一个你不需要的烤面包机。有些经济学家甚至提出，实际上我们应该做的是交易礼品卡和现金，因为我们最终实际上不会互相购买不需要的东西。但当然，这遇到了令人反感交易的问题，也就是说，如果我真的在每个生日或周年纪念日给我的伴侣或朋友现金，我不会被视为一个很好的朋友。
Right. So I think that wedding registries are a very interesting development address to that problem. So here's a couple getting married and perhaps if they're young and first married and all of those things, they're starting a new household. So there was this idea that they need all sorts of pots and pans and linens and all of that. But if their friends just give them what they feel like giving them, they may end up with lots of big red pots and not enough linen. Whereas if their friends were to give them money, they could use it to buy what they wanted and needed, but giving them money seems cold. So you see wedding registries, they can go to a big retailer and choose the linen they want
没错。所以我认为婚礼注册表是一个非常有趣的针对该问题的解决方案。所以这是一对正在结婚的夫妇，也许如果他们很年轻，刚结婚以及所有这些情况，他们正在建立一个新家庭。所以有这样一种想法：他们需要各种锅碗瓢盆、床单和所有这些东西。但如果他们的朋友只是给他们觉得想给的东西，他们最终可能会得到很多大红锅，而床单不够。然而，如果他们的朋友给他们钱，他们可以用它来买他们想要和需要的东西，但给他们钱显得很冷冰冰。所以你会看到婚礼注册表，他们可以去一家大型零售商那里选择他们想要的床单、
and the pots they want and the silverware they want. And you can sign up to buy them the linen or the pots or a bunch of steak knives or something like that. So that's very close to giving them money because once someone has bought them steak knives, you can't buy them steak knives on the registry anymore. It'll say that that's already been bought. So there's obviously a cleverness here, which is, wedding registries are a way to essentially design out the repugnance in what actually might be a repugnant transaction.
他们想要的锅和他们想要的银器。你可以注册为他们购买床单或锅或一堆牛排刀或类似的东西。这非常接近于直接给他们钱，因为一旦有人为他们买了牛排刀，你就不能再在注册表上为他们买牛排刀了。系统会显示那已经被买走了。所以这里显然有一种聪明之处，即婚礼注册表本质上是一种设计掉可能实际上是令人反感交易中的反感的方式。
You have done a lot of thinking out about how to apply, and some ways a similar kind of insight to the world of kidney donations, and it doesn't involve buying and selling kidneys, but something else that's actually much more clever. What have you done? Well, so if so recall that we talked about how in-kind exchanges might, might be acceptable when exchanges for money or not. And part of the great shortage of kidneys for transplantation has to do with the fact that you can't compensate kidney donors. But what we do is something called kidney exchange. It turns out a healthy person has two kidneys and can remain healthy with one.
你一直在深入思考如何应用，在某些方面，将类似的深刻见解应用到肾脏捐赠的世界中，它不涉及买卖肾脏，而是涉及其他实际上更聪明的事情。你做了什么？嗯，所以如果回想一下我们讨论过的为什么实物交换可能是可以接受的，而金钱交换则不然。肾脏移植的巨大短缺部分原因在于你不能补偿肾脏捐赠者。但我们所做的是所谓的肾脏交换。事实证明，一个健康的人有两个肾，少了一个也能保持健康。
And so if you love someone who's dying from kidney failure, you might be able to save their life by giving them one of your kidneys. But sometimes it happens that you're healthy enough to give someone a kidney but you can't give it to the person you love because it turns out kidneys have to be very well matched to the to the recipient. So it used to be that if you wanted to give a kidney to someone and were healthy enough to do it, but you couldn't give it to the person you love, you would just be sent home. And the person you loved would continue the long dangerous wait for a deceased donor organ, which could take years and is full of hazards.
因此，如果你爱的人正在因肾衰竭而濒临死亡，你或许可以通过把你的一个肾送给他们来拯救他们的生命。但有时会发生这种情况：你足够健康可以把肾捐给别人，但你不能把它捐给你爱的人，因为事实证明肾脏必须与受体高度匹配。因此，过去如果你想把肾捐给某人而且身体足够健康可以做到，但你不能把它捐给你爱的人，你就会被直接送回家。而你爱的人将继续漫长而危险地等待逝者器官，这可能需要数年时间，并且充满风险。
But now what we can do is we can say, you know, you are healthy enough to give a kidney, but you can't give it to the person you love. And maybe I'm healthy enough to give a kidney, but I can't give it to the person I love, but I could give a kidney to your patient, and you could give a kidney to my patient and through that exchange of kidneys without any money changing hands we would legally and ethically have found a way to create two more transplants than would have happened otherwise. Through simple exchanges like that and through more complex exchanges that involve chains of kidney donation, kidney exchange has become a standard form of transplantation in the United States now. And I understand that some of these
但现在我们可以做的是，你知道，你身体足够健康可以捐肾，但你不能把它捐给你爱的人。也许我身体足够健康可以捐肾，但我不能把它捐给我爱的人，但我可以把一个肾捐给你的病人，你可以把一个肾捐给我的病人，通过这种没有金钱易手的肾脏交换，我们在法律上和伦理上找到了一种方法，创造出比原本更多移植手术。通过像这样的简单交换以及涉及肾脏捐赠链的更复杂交换，肾脏交换现在已经成为美国移植的标准形式。而且据我了解，其中一些
are extraordinarily complex. They can involve much more than two individuals. They can involve 10, 20 or even 30 people in a very complex exchange. Right, so the complex exchanges begin with with non-directed donors. Sometimes someone wants to donate a kidney and they don't have a particular patient in mind. And those non-directed donors can start long chains of donations where they give a kidney to a patient who with his prospective donor are waiting for an exchange. And the donor of that kidney patient passes it forward and gives to another patient and the donor of that kidney patient passes it forward and gives to
异常复杂。它们可以涉及远不止两个人。它们可以在一个非常复杂的交换中涉及10、20甚至30人。没错，所以复杂的交换始于非定向捐赠者。有时有人想要捐献一个肾脏，并且他们心里并没有特定的患者。这些非定向捐赠者可以开启漫长的捐赠链，他们将肾脏捐给一个正在等待交换的患者及其潜在捐赠者。该患者的肾脏捐赠者将其传递并捐给另一个患者，该患者的捐赠者将其传递并捐给
another patient and the donor from that patient passes it forward. Some of those chains have been very long and have you know when you look at a set of photographs afterwards they can have 60 or 70 people in them. So 30 or 35 transplants and and an equal number of nephrectomies. The average chain in the United States has 10 people in the picture, five donations and five transplants, so it's become a very effective way of amplifying the gift. What's interesting, of course, is that this is mindful of both the psychology and the economics of repugnant transactions.
另一个患者，该患者的捐赠者将其传递下去。其中一些链条非常长，你知道，当你事后看一组照片时，里面可能会有60或70人。也就是30或35次移植手术，以及等量的肾切除术。美国平均链条里有10个人在照片中，五次捐赠和五次移植，所以它已经成为放大这份礼物的非常有效的方法。当然，有趣的是，这既考虑到了令人反感交易的心理学，又考虑到了经济学。
It's not saying, let's do away with them entirely and have a market for kidneys because that runs into other problems. And it's not sort of saying, let's actually just ignore the problem altogether. It's saying, let's actually keep these concerns front and center and essentially design around them to get what we want without sort of sacrificing
它不是说，让我们彻底废除它们，建立一个肾脏市场，因为那会遇到其他问题。它也不是说，让我们实际上完全忽视这个问题。它是说，让我们把这些关切放在最前面和中心位置，并通过设计绕过它们，在不牺牲
our moral qualms about buying and selling organs. I think that's exactly right. So it satisfies, I think, those who have moral qualms about buying and selling. And it also is, even if you don't have moral qualms about buying and selling, when you see something that's against the law almost everywhere in the world, you might correctly figure out that it wouldn't be an easy thing to change. And if you want to help people who have kidney disease today, you have to find a way of doing it that doesn't arouse replugments even if you don't feel it yourself.
我们对买卖器官的道德疑虑的情况下，获得我们想要的东西。我认为这绝对是正确的。所以它满足了那些对买卖持有道德疑虑的人。而且，即使你对买卖没有道德疑虑，当你看到某件在世界几乎各地都违背法律的事情时，你可能会正确地推断出改变它并非易事。如果你想帮助今天患有肾脏疾病的人，你必须找到一种不会引起反感的方法来做到这一点，即使你自己并不觉得反感。
Alvin Roth is an economist at Stanford University. He won the 2012 Nobel Prize in Economics. You can read more about his ideas at marketdesigner.blogspot.com. Al, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you for having me. This week's show was produced by Path Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu, and Laura Quarelle. Our unsung hero this week is Marco Martire. For the past few years, Marco has managed sound bites, the cafeteria at NPR.
埃尔温·罗斯是斯坦福大学的经济学家。他获得了2012年诺贝尔经济学奖。你可以在marketdesigner.blogspot.com上阅读更多关于他的理念。埃尔，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。哦，谢谢邀请我。本期节目由帕特·沙阿制作。由塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸雷尔。我们本周的无名英雄是马科·马尔蒂雷。在过去的几年里，马科一直管理着NPR的自助餐厅“声音咬一口”。
He's always upbeat, he remembers people's names. This was Marco's last week at NPR. When I talked to him recently, he said he's going to be launching a cafeteria at a new location because he's done so well here. I reminded him that this was the danger of demonstrating competence. Thank you Marco. Reminded him that this was the danger of demonstrating competence. Thank you, Marco. One last thing before we wrap today, we're just getting started on a episode about workplace culture. Have you ever witnessed something troubling or inappropriate at work and
他总是乐观开朗，能记住每个人的名字。这是马尔科在NPR的最后一周。我最近和他交谈时，他说他将在一个新的地点开办一家自助餐厅，因为他在这里干得非常出色。我提醒他，这就是展现能力的风险。谢谢你，马尔科。提醒他这就是展现能力的风险。谢谢你，马尔科。在我们今天的节目结束前还有最后一件事，我们刚刚开始制作一期关于职场文化的节目。你是否曾在工作场所目睹过令人不安或不当的事情，并
struggled with whether to remain silent or speak up about it. If you're willing to talk about what happened, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at HiddenBrain at npr.org. Be sure to include a phone number where we can reach you. That email address again is HiddenBrain at npr.org. Please use the subject line, workplace. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
纠结于是保持沉默还是说出来。如果你愿意讲述当时发生的事情，请用手机录一段语音备忘录，并发送至我们的邮箱 HiddenBrain@npr.org。请务必留下可以联系到你的电话号码。再次重复邮箱地址是 HiddenBrain@npr.org。邮件主题请填写“职场”。我是香卡·维丹坦，这里是NPR。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。